I will be going over the basics of react
in this video react is a JavaScript
library for building user interfaces it
uses a concept called the virtual Dom
that selectively renders sections based
upon state changes and it's great for
making single page apps it is used by
sites such as Facebook and Instagram
when you first start a project you have
to make sure you include react in your
project code pin makes it easy if you're
using code pin you just click on the
little gear icon here and then under
JavaScript I already have react included
you want to include two things if you
don't have included already you're gonna
go to this quick add and you're gonna
scroll down and you're gonna go to react
right here and then after you click here
you're gonna open up the quick add again
and then you're gonna click to react Dom
you need both those things react and
react Dom and then you have to go to the
JavaScript preprocessor and you have to
make sure a Babel is selected this is
going to allow you to use JSX I'll tell
you more about JSX later in the video
after you have it set up you can start
creating a react project I have a simple
page here that's been created and react
before I go into the details of what's
what all this stuff is I want to show
you that in the HTML section here I just
have one thing it's a div with an ID of
container the CSS I just have something
to create a bigger font size for
everything so it's easier to see on the
screen so let's go over to the
JavaScript the cool thing about react is
that you can create a whole webpage just
basically in JavaScript so this right
here is a component your components tell
react what you want to render and then
react will efficiently update and render
just the right components when your data
changes usually your project will
consist of many different components
that go together and then you have this
line here react down that render when
we're going to render our main component
which is shopping list and we can pass
in a prop I'll tell you more about that
later and then you have the next
argument is where the
the component is going to render we have
documented that get element by ID
container so that's going to select this
container up here in the HTML and then
it's going to render your react
component here shopping list is a react
component class components taken
parameters called props and return views
to display so the parameter that
shopping list is taking in is down here
name equals Bo it's going to take in
this four so here's the name of the
component and here's the parameter we're
gonna pass in to the shopping list
component it's also gonna return this
view to display so it's going to return
all this stuff right here is the view
that's going to display this part kind
of looks like HTML but it's actually
called JSX
you don't have to use JSX but it makes
things much easier because it's so
similar to write HTML which many people
already know JSX
always has to be completely surrounded
with one tag what I mean it's you know
it starts with a div tag it ends with a
div tag if I tried to add another tag
here like a PT ad or something it's
gonna mess things up unless if I do add
a P tag I would have to start put
another div tag at the beginning and
then surround the whole thing with what
div so I have to just add another div
here but we're going to delete all this
stuff because we don't need it for this
project and it already starts with a div
tag and ends with a div tag also there
are some differences between JSX and
HTML instead of class you're gonna use
classname mainly because class is
reserved word and JavaScript there's a
few other minor differences but for the
most part you can write it pretty
similar to HTML inside the JSX you can
put these curly braces and inside those
curly braces you can have any valid
JavaScript inside here we have a
variable name which is the prop that's
passed in so when I pass in this name Bo
I can access it just like this this that
props that name now just realize that in
the
display here I still have something that
that's not actually in the code so let
me rerun this okay so that's what it
should look like now the other part we
are going to be adding later so this
right here is being displayed right here
we have shopping list for Bo and you can
see it's displaying wherever your
shopping list for Bo and then we have
this list here and the list is being
displayed right here around on the
webpage now I'm going to add a little
more to the code and react you have
different components and the components
form a hierarchy you usually build
components making each additional
component a child of the previous
component I'm going to take out these
list items right here and create a list
item component we are just putting in a
variable which is going to be all the
list items we're gonna fill this
variable with the list items in just a
minute but first I'm going to show how
you create another component up here so
here is the the list item component so
we have the shopping list component here
and then we have the list item component
here that we're going to include in the
shopping list component
I haven't finished showing exactly how
to include it yet this list component is
actually a simpler way to write
components called a stateless functional
component this is four components to
only have a render method rather than
define a class extending react that
component you simply just write a
function that takes props and returns
what should be rendered so it's going to
take in props here and it's going to
return which should be rendered which
just is just a list item and then inside
the list items we have props that item
this is something we have to pass in to
this component right now both of these
just renders see we just have the render
command here we have the render command
here but I'm gonna add more methods to
shopping list components later this list
item component only just renders the one
item that's passed in I'm gonna create
the list as a state in the shopping list
component so I just put in
code inside the shopping list component
this is to help create the state of the
list and then we're going to pass each
item of the list that we have stored as
state and a shopping list component into
the list item component and then that
state becomes props the key difference
between props and state is that state is
internal and controlled by the component
itself
well--perhaps are external and
controlled by whatever renders the
component this will make more sense as I
explained this example but state and
props are key ideas and react anything
inside this constructor function is just
run one time at the very beginning of
the program in JavaScript classes you
need to explicitly call super when
defining the constructor of a subclass
and this is where you're going to define
your state variables the list state is
owned by the shopping list component and
the state can only be updated by the
shopping list component will pass the
items on the list as props to the list
item component but the list iron
component cannot make any changes to the
items because they're owned by the
shopping list component well let me
finish create the code that will show
you how this state actually ends up in
the the list item up here so I'm gonna
go to this render method down here okay
let's look at this we are gonna create
this variable as just an empty array
called list items and then we have this
loop here this that state that lists
that's how we're getting this list here
this list here is this that state that
lists and then we're gonna do a for each
loop for each item in this loop we're
gonna use the item which is unicycle
juggling clubs and stilts and this
second thing is just the index of the
items we're gonna do list items dot push
so we're pushing each of the list items
onto this array but now we're gonna
actually use some JSX here so it's going
to have this tag the list item in the
tag and that list item is this list item
so we are going to pass in one of these
list items
opponents into the array and inside the
list item component we are going to put
in two props so use the first prop item
equals item so there's going to be a
prop called item and that the value of
that prop is item and we get the item
from here and we're inside Jess actually
gonna use curly braces to put in
JavaScript so this was gonna be each of
the items on the list and then we are
going to pass in another prop called
on click now you can pass in variables
but you can also pass in functions so
the on click is going to pass in this on
click function which we have not created
yet so we're gonna pass in the variable
and we're going to pass on click as a
function now before I create the on
click function we're going to use the on
click function up here so in the list
items component I'm just going to add
this on click equals props dot on click
now we still don't know what that
function is doing so that's what I'm
gonna create now we are going to create
the onclick function in the shopping
list component so here's the on click
function now I'm passing in a function
created in this component so I'm putting
in a list item component but I'm passing
in the onclick is gonna equal a function
in this component so now the the list
item component can access the onclick
function that's inside the shopping list
component so let's look at what the
onclick function is going to be doing we
got var new list equals this that state
that list that slice so remember that
this that state that list is this list
here slice is just going to copy the
list and then we're going to do new list
that splice index one so we're passing
in an index and it's passed in here see
when we when we pass in this prop on
click we're putting the index I that are
coming from the four
each loop and this is just going to when
we do splice it's just going to delete
one item at the index so this onclick
event is just to delete an item on the
list and then we're gonna do this that
set state list is new list so here's
where we initialize the state and inside
the state we have a list that's going to
equal this list but now we're going to
create a new list that deletes the item
that's clicked on and we're going to do
this that set state list is new list so
it's just a way to delete an item on a
list by clicking it by creating a copy
of the list array instead of changing
the original array it increases
component and overall application
performance before we ex are using
JavaScript classes down here you would
not have to use the the arrow function
but now you have to use an arrow
function so the word this will bind
correctly basically without this arrow
function here the word this would be
referring to the wrong thing and you'll
get an error so now let's run this and
just just give it a test here so if I
click juggling close it deletes the clip
unicycle it deletes so see what that's
what's happening here I'm gonna run it
again if it whenever you rerun the
project it will start it from scratch
that's how I got these to reappear here
so let's just go over really quick
what's happening we have the constructor
where we're going to create this list
now we're gonna push each item onto the
list like this so it's gonna push a list
item which is basically just these Li
tags with the onclick it's going to
bring in the onclick function from the
shopping list component and for that
item it's going to push in one item at a
time from this for each array so since
there's three items in the list the
unicycle juggling Club in stilts there's
going to be three list item components
in this list an array then we're going
to return all this stuff here including
this array of list items so we have the
unordered list tag and then the list
items is just all these
list item tags get pushed into the array
which ends up creating this list and
since we have this on click event when a
click it just automatically updates by
removing the item so the last thing I
want to add is just a way to create the
items without just restarting everything
okay I just added these two lines of
code and I'm going to run this so it
appears on the website here and we just
have a text box we have a button that
says add and you can see we have the ID
of the text box is list item and in the
button we have an on click event in the
button and we've passed in using these
curly braces we passed in the this dot
add item function and again uses the new
arrow functions but the key part is the
dista add item this is a function within
this component that we have not created
yet so right now if i right now i can
put in here that push add it doesn't
really do anything that's because we
haven't we haven't created this function
yet so let me create the add item
function okay here we go here's the add
item function so let's go through what
this does so we have our item equals
document that get element by ID list
item not value
so remember when we create in the JSX or
a kind of HTML down here we have this
imp IM with the ID of list item so when
we do the get element by ID list and
that value that's going to give us
whatever is inside this text box here
then we have document dot get element by
ID list item that value equals blank so
after we get the item that's in the
textbox we want to change that text to
an empty string so basically after you
click add item the word won't be in the
text box anymore that's what this line
is for because we've already used that
word and then we're just like on the on
click here where we're going to slice
the list to create a copy of it we're
going to create a new copy here is new
list and then we're gonna push the item
onto the new list new list up push
item this I am we got from the text box
and then just like the on click event
we're going to do this that set state
list is new list let me refresh this
whole thing here and let's test it out
if we add cereal and then I click Add
yep
see that went away from here and then it
added to the list if I put juggling
balls and then I click Add it's gonna
add two lists and I can click valiums to
take him off the list
oh gosh you know but now I want more
cereal let's add that again when you
call the this that step set State and
the component using list is
automatically updated on the website now
this list this shopping list for bow app
is just a pretty basic example of what
you can do with react but hopefully you
see how powerful and all these
components can be to create bigger and
bigger apps this was just a brief
introduction but I'm gonna be doing more
react videos in the future
thanks for watching my name is beau
Carnes you can check the description for
the code from this video so you can try
all this stuff out yourself don't forget
to subscribe and remember use your code
for good